questi se vuoi e lei ovviamente non
posso complicare le foto che motivi tra
voglio dire una cosa
spiegherò come rimorchiare una superstar
fai partire il titolo in sovrimpressione
come rimorchiare una superstar
per chi non lo sapesse ma in realtà lo
sanno tutti ormai per il tipo di stile
di vita di gabriele gabriele è uno
stuntman utenti non ce ne frega un cazzo
l'ha provato con lady gaga ha ovviamente
abbiamo avuto la fortuna di incontrarci
tra celebrità sul set di pulci in questo
caso è in te ti è una persona
eccezionale ma non altrettanto miei
andiamo l'ordine che cosa è successo si
è presentata sul set come lady gaga
giusto ma dal vivo ti accorgi che ha un
sacco di fragilità le enormi fragilità e
io le ho captate tutte e 16 le cartelle
dei cinque chilometri di distanza
io stavo io lady gaga ridley ad andrei
per jared leto al pacino del trucco i
migliori artisti del mondo al pacino e
ridley scott e segnai capire scippata
breve gilles va bene nel suo campo
quando al bacino e venuto sul set tutti
gli altri attori sono diventati delle
comparse è venuto da noi stenta a
parlare l'idea scherzato siamo ammazzate
le risate che è successo che stefan si è
sentita messa da parte
mi è caduta nella trappola del fattore
cerca per il a meno di una arrivato al
che palesava per chiedere al ciao bello
quando al pacino è venuto a parlare con
me in maniera prorompente possiamo dire
frequente c'era un soleil e subito dalla
serie partita venendo a cercare di
prendersi la scena c'è ma noi stamo
palla non poteva non poterono ciò
dell'assurdo e leggo da lì e poi cercava
di barcamenarsi per cercare di avere
attenzione nostra che invece sta con la
stessa guai
e c'era e lì ho visto la partita della
ragazza lì non era più news italia ma
era strana se tali e io ero diventato
caprile scilla per prima cosa no però
capito che la lady gaga ad eric h ok a
gaga ok cantiere mamma arriva al bacino
a parlare con tempi e le dica che
ascende esterna ogni giorno lotta
trasformazione mari germanotta che viene
internato nei cieli la fiacca e sale o
profittato sandalo rientro che cosa c'è
anche tipo ma il resto non lo posso
raccontarlo abbiamo sempre che esista
della comunicazione senti di dire quello
che avrei fatto
le ho chiesto che cosa non andasse no e
poi si è detto felice nel milan dando
governo oppure cerchi qualcosa di più e
lei ha riconosciuto il testo della sua
canzone ormai è stata così come san
magno luci ho fatto tutto a posto e
risolto perché appena uscita la notizia
degli anni che ha fatto adesso dove vive
la ritrovai tina signora non so se rai
ha dato i soldi che io lo so ma non
voglio grazie era contenta ed ai e una
il senso di gucci mangiamo noi tutti da
gabriele al pacino al lager gen
ma laura insieme quelli con cui lo più
legato sono stati anni c'è tutta
un'allergia cazzo de fine fatto bene sa
far male con sono solo abbronzato posso
metterlo a delle creme mettermi barlays
in famiglia per e alla fine
questo che mi fermarono le cose disse
adesso mi e questo sta la stessa
condizione mia c'è una persona che vi
rinuncia aveva già notato al pacino le
superstar c'hanno questo fatto che in
realtà cercano normalità
mi ha chiesto di fare il duetto con lei
di jean poi resi da noi questo non lo
puntare montano si perdeva detto meglio
di bradley cooper a facciamo entrarono
chitarra per favore mi sto mettendo di
creme compri che sto prendendo così
tanta vita che mi davano io facevo
bradley e le faceva lady gaga mi ha
spiegato i trucchi di charlot che
nessuno conosce questo è un blues e con
lui ripensi e per ciò che gli accordi
state miniere tra giorgio che stesso b
[Musica]
la senti queste stallo ma si riconosce
subito perdere
[Musica]
ti racconto proprio come è stata la
nostra storia
pensate qui la voce più alta perché ti
sta domandando mi ha detto lei un
ragazzo della tv fuori con l'anima
questa è una canzone di anna e cioè che
a gaga è che l'ambiente maccari e quanto
needle ce n'è sempre una traduzione
cassetto così è scusato spiegando come
[Musica]
questo è un affermazione va una domanda
di aiuto iphone
[Musica]
e non mi ricordo le parole
noi facciamo entrare facciamo entrare
una cosa cosi affidati che se ti viene
meno si parla come ti pare
[Musica]
non è proprio così a parte gr dovresti
canta realtà ma non la so che non sente
il vibrato non gira a vuoto ma ha detto
stephanie ma ci sono cascato quando mi
[Musica]
aspettavo
ho capito
[Musica]
[Applauso]
bravissimo come dice stefani quando
l'anima piange tu non senti la voce come
battisti che
[Applauso]
[Musica]
per fallo è innocua di gand alto perché
io so presley e anders alla hai visto
che la deve fare sempre un po di lei
stava sul cazzo perché prende li fa così
john mensah nonno e scilla duncan gaga
bamboo bag lei senza saperlo ho sempre
cercato quindi gaga
[Musica]
un rito rom rumeni
sheldon
[Musica]
ma il pezzo più bello da quando stanno
al piano alla notte degli oscar esempio
rimasti così posso togliermi questa
parrucca so che ti manca gabriele
magrini alti forze e ovviamente era
molto presa da te che io a livello
artistico la considero eccezionale ma
per le puntine molto e sono certo
andiamo al dunque come rimorchiare una
superstar
perché avete copiato postali
internazionali è ok chiusi e shakira che
gelò generazioni
justin bieber ecco prendiamo una shakira
ammessa mila piace molto felice ma i
passi il robot certo che lo rendono
altamente nell indifferenza della vita o
prendiamo una shakira è una ragazza
molto semplice la classica superstar
alla ricerca di una normalità
non possiamo ad estrarla con ochhio
neanche però poi farmaco ma non so
pensato che fossi tutti nell'esercito
tedesco con lo score fusti chi non si
piace ci avrà dei difetti
eccolo qua guarda qui quasi una
prontezza il segno della varicella che è
quello che c'è pure io ti scriviamo le
subito non le ho mai scritto mai scritto
ciao marcellina un vezzeggiativo che
tutti hanno dato questa cosa e basta ci
diciamo e cellini la scuola ci parla la
metti non neanche deve essere troppo di
ovada apprende il bambino a scuola
fidanzata da 11 anni monaco pil e che ci
ha fatto periti quindi adesso ho la
placa lo stadio del barcellona che aveva
spesso a vedere partire oppure c'è la
dobbiamo coinvolgere assomigli tanti tra
l'altro non c'è manco la barriera
linguistica perché ne parla italiano che
vanta cinque lingue
anzi le scriviamo così ciao margellina
au petit quali è scritto how e schiera
la capisce le veloce ma non so di cosa
stai parlando né criticato linee acuti
di lady gaga ma sta insegnando un cazzo
non tomista non noto non mi aprì l ho
visto una persona che non mi piace
davanti scuola
le menti sto informando tutti no però
così pare dice io malori molti ha
lasciati che è proprio un doppio attacco
tu scrivi a piquet ciao jerry a 1 perché
se un po in calisse vicenza vediamo se
possiamo minare la coppia augeri chavari
ciellina complimenti per la partita
quale ha perso il barcellona lo so cose
che direbbe chiunque li esatto a cielo
ci hanno una villa barcellona sto
cercando casa nella zona della tua villa
ma certo che tu sappia ti fanno storie
se fai la rus ti mangia mai visto
livello però che operiamo e una sorella
non tempi rimorchiate lea l'altro giorno
non eri allo stadio iniziò così capita
poi dico senti presa e salsiccia di 96
fermata mi mancano le chiacchiere ci
facevamo allo stadio perché chiedo
rubate aperti sto insegnando io come che
mi spetta
mentre tuo marito mentre il
coordinamento mentre gerry giocava
intelligenti lasciata sola si lede un
vita in qualche posto che venne isolato
non paparazzato cinema roma ma roma
cerca questi ci vediamo a tor bella
monaca a roma
non puoi dire di aver assaggiato deve a
carbonara sin dalla prima assaggiato il
mio capo che faccio io ma io non la
faccio
tracce di esko 7 ore stiamo a mandare un
messaggio shakira non ti si cagherà mai
io sono tutto ciò che nella tua vita
manca per tutto il resto povertà
bruttezza ragusa c'è la mazza
quindi cosa è stato terribile all'amo
stadio mentre si lasciava
ho scritto male moore guarda ti faccio
vedere una persona più semplici come
cazzo si chiama la madre dei granchi la
madre tea che la tecnica e mettere like
alle prime foto di quando per la persona
ancora non era la granda che c'è like mi
piace legge merlin l'action figure di
tenaris filo sapere era un po stravecchi
mi piace mie dell'ego maialone guarda
come mente like to know thy dai
quadranti da un messico acqua c'è uno
quindi non lo metto quindi già se
curiosi se dice che questo campione
scilla che mi ha messo mi piacevi ancor
prima di essere la madre dei draghi
adesso che sei borana questo video è una
presa in giro
se un tutorial adesso mi sarei store on
banking english for the non ha scritto
in crescita che lo lascio così fitti
fitti così l'ho fatto di proposito per
una delle tecniche e che la juventus era
interesse non è scrivere qualcosa di
senso compiuto mai creare un gap che
incuriosisca la donna dire ma in che
senso stretto lei sta già copiando
incollando su google tra slitta e adesso
ne mando al comunale
io lo so l'emozione non ha voce e anima
in campo respiro
se ci sei mai prezzi del respiro no ma
il prof
c'è troppa luce gara canina
secondo clarke è piaciuto my breath
questa ora sono pazzo anch'io che lei
passa pronto pronto fra un po c'è nessun
dubbio cometa mottola diciamo che queste
tecniche sono un po arrugginite
posso provare se ho imparato ma torna
nella sosta shakira la sorte mine clarke
tech e ho lasciato la moto nostra sul
set
siccome io sta settimana non credo di
esserci che sto facendo l'altro film la
potresti prendere tu grazie che se loro
non dote personale poi che li senti un
mio amico si è rotto il tallone
d'achille tu conosci qualcuno di bravo
per operarlo perché non mi fido mandarlo
capito pronto soccorso in questo periodo
copit time associato un aspetto che non
dico io che ha scritto un amico mio e
sarai chiave detto la massoneria
cristiano e urgente
cristiano era urgente mi sta mandando ai
messaggi sono preoccupato perché va
operato subito
fammi sapere o tendine d'achille aspetta
ciao creed volevo sapere se potevi
chiudere il video qui e cr7 sta per
chiudere il video era stato male mi puoi
fare un favore che è una cosa è chiara
sempre tutti quanti potresti scrivere al
mio canale su youtube
ti lascio il link to click in ciò che
niente ancora alcune persone guardano i
video ma patema così scrivono e se
riguardano questi video musicale non
avrebbe nessuna altra ma detto cristiano
ronaldo potresti fare una piccola
richiesta ai tuoi utenti poi su youtube
qui il muscia e di cliccare su iscriviti
facilissimo che attivi la calma relina
quasi un po di video le havre e
mettetele anche a caso ma la cosa più
importante iscriversi si iscrive
iscrivermi a non parlare aspetta che sto
per disfare eminem è un maremoto prima
qui funziona tuttavia carson palla mi è
la debba ricondurre valpe chiamata 40
pensate visto scarico consiglio perché
c'è un pezzo bellissimo di san leonardo
te lo chiedo una cosa ma su quella porta
c'è poter risalire o è stato il regista
che credo che finge di cadere risponde
sul mio ciao cechi sono sempre io sono
un logo
no niente devo dire che la sento sempre
per radio e sarebbe carino se la
sentissimo insieme macchine vai vai se
non essere carino nel prossimo video
dobbiamo contattare la distrazione
profili che ci vedi contattare qua sotto
tamin da tavole di sperare che qualcuno
invece risponde a quelli che prendono
più voti ora noi contattati questa
figura di merda la faccia ma voi siete
una cosa così come per me trovare una
persona su instagram e premere il
pulsante dire ciao cristiano ronaldo
ciao justin ma babel ben capito quella
roba lì così come me non costa niente
prendere un tasto
non costa niente premere il bottone
iscritti di ragazzi ma fatica con cosa
deve vedere video rompe il tendine
cosa devo fare per impietosirmi come
capisci la sentendo ogni volta lo chiede
all'inizio cosa devo fare io vi meritate
vorrei dire vera e molto forti
vi meritate di essere lì che verrà ri
abeni shakira come la essere comunque io
amo stava scherzando shakira io me la
mela va bè ragazzi detto ciò il mondo
maggio grande grazie cambierebbe per
questo video costo attivo ci vediamo
domenica con la puntata di luce non
votare
[Musica]